WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE HEARING
SERGEANTS CAR CALL THE MISSING
A COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND HAVE
THEM COME UP AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. WELCOME TO THE
CONTINUES TO HOME ORDER WE'RE
ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE IN HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE
TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN
THE HEARING IN PERSON. WE'RE
ALSO REQUIRING THE MOUSE. BE
WARNED AND PHYSICAL DISNEY
DISTANCING BE MAINTAINED BY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING. WHETHER YOU'RE HERE
IN THE ROOM OR AT THE VIDEO
CONFERENCE SITE IF YOU DO NOT
HAVE A MASS WE CAN PROVIDE YOU
WITH ONE. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TEST FROM THE BILL
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND NOW
ASK YOUR PRO SOME MICROPHONE.
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. WHAT
ELSE THAT THE PUBLIC DO NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU CAN
EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU
ARE DONE TESTIFYING OR RETURN
TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCE UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL. INCLUDING
LIMITED. INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USE THAT ONE PERSON AT
THE TIME. FOR DAHLEN WITNESSES
THERE ALSO BE USED IN A
MODERATE TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH- ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THISHEARING IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. AS WELL AS
ON YOUR TV SCREEN. YOU FOR
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING IS ON THE
BEGINNING OF THE BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WE GIVE INSTRUCTION ON
HOW TO BE PLACED IN THE QUEUE.
BASED ON WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE THE BILL. FOR CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIFE YOUR BROADCAST. AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATE PHONE SYSTEM YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
SIX AREA CODE. THREE ONE NINE
THREE NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND MY
STUFF WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO
HELP. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT
WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGHOUT THE
POSITION. LETTER PARTIAL OF THE
COMMISSION ASAMBLEíSTA.
BECAUSE OF TIME CONSTRAINTS AND
THE NEED TO LIMIT HOW LONG
PHONE LINES ARE OPEN FOR EACH
BILL. I'M ASKING EVERYONE WHO
CALLS IN TO VERIFY BRIEFLY IN
THE REMARKS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE WITH THAT SAID LET'S
GET STARTED WE HAVE THREE ITEMS
ON THE AGENDA TODAY. AB TWENTY
ONE OH ONE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT
WAS REFERRED TO A COMMITTEE
EARLIER THIS AFTERNOON SO THAT
BILL IS ALSO ON THE AGENDA.
MISTER SECTOR PLEASE COLORADO
STRUCTURE QUORUM. RODRIGUEZ
HERE. WE'LL TELL. CERVANTES
COOLEY. WHO WORK. FONG WHAT ARE
YOUR. ASSEMBLY MODEL. SO NOT
SOME SORT OF FORM WE CAN GO
AHEAD AND START AS A SUB SUB
COMMITTEE. AND WITH THAT WE DO
HAVE- SOME REMEMBER STONE WHO'S
HERE IF YOU LIKE TO COME FOR TO
PRESENT. THANK YOU VERY
MEMBERS. THIS IS THE BILL THAT
IS VERY VERY SPECIFIC TO FIRE
AGENCIES IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY.
THESE AGENCIES HAVE BEEN
WORKING TOGETHER FOR A LONG
TIME TO. COME UP WITH AN
AGREEMENT TO CONSOLIDATE IN THE
CONSOLIDATION IS AROUND FISCAL
AND PROCESS EFFICIENCIES IN IN
THE COUNTY THEIR NUMBER FIRE
DISTRICTS THAT ARE FUNCTIONING
THERE. THEY CAME TO AGREEMENT
WITH EMPLOYEES CAME TO
AGREEMENT WITH THE BOARDS AND
EVERYTHING EXCEPT THAT THEY
WERE LEFT WITH THE CHALLENGE
WITH THE PERSON STATUS BECAUSE
WHAT WE WANT TO TRY TO DO AND
WHAT WITH THE AGREEMENT WAS WAS
GIVING ALL OF THE EMPLOYEES.
THE BENEFIT THAT THEY HAD
UNDER THE PERS RULES THAT IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO DO THEY THEY HAVE
THEY CAN'T WRITE A CONTRACT.
THAT CONTEMPLATES DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES OF EMPLOYEES. EXCEPT
IN THE CASE OF THAT PEPPER
RULES WHERE THEY THE NEW
EMPLOYEES WOULD DEFINITELY COME
UNDER DIFFERENT COMING UNDER
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT TERMS SO WE
WANT TO PURSUE AND TRY TO WORK
SOMETHING OUT WITH THEM. AND
THE THROUGH THEIR CREATIVITY
THEY CAME UP WITH WHAT IS IN
THIS BILL IT ALLOWS THE PROCESS
TO MOVE FORWARD IN SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY AND BECAUSE IT'S BACK
DATED THEN ONCE THAT
CONSOLIDATION HAPPENS THEY CAN
GO TO PERS NEGOTIATED CONTRACT.
ON THE TERMS THAT THE EMPLOYEES
NOW ARE EXPECTING TO GET.
THROUGH THEIR NEGOTIATION SO I
HAVE TO THANK PER STAFF FOR
COMING UP WITH THIS CREATIVE.
SOLUTION TO THIS WE WORK PRETTY
CLOSELY WITH THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND OTHERS THERE AS
WELL AS TO THE AGENCIES TO
LASKO. TO ALL THE PARTIES
INVOLVED IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
SO THAT'S WHAT THIS FIX IS ALL
ABOUT AND I APPRECIATE GRABBED.
THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER SO THE
SCORE REMAINED WINLESS ON THE
BILL WE HAVE ON THE PHONE. SO
THAT I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
CHRISTIE BALMA. WAS ON THE
PHONE- THE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A
FEW MINUTES OF YOUR PRIMER WHEN
THIS. OPERATOR DO WE HAVE A
CHRISTIE BALMA. IT'S ONE ZERO.
FIFTY BALMA. SORRY THERE'S NO
CRYSTAL BALL LAW SHOWING UP.
THE OPERATOR WE CAN GO TO THE
PHONE IS THERE ANY OTHERS A TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY SUPPORT. OF
SYSTEMS AB. ELEVEN FORTY. BOTH
ON THE PHONE IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE OF THEM THEY'RE ALL
AT THIS TIME. IT'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT. WE JUST WITNESSED.
SEARCH TO RECALL THE ROADS WERE
WAITING FOR THE PHONE LINE- TO
ESTABLISH KERR. COOPER PRESS
THE MIXTURE WE HAVE A QUORUM.
WE HAVE A QUORUM CONTINUE
OPERATORS ARE ANYBODY IN THE
QUEUE. YES THEY HAVE Y. NUMBER
EIGHTEEN COULD GO AHEAD. POLICE
RETIREMENT SYSTEM IT'S A PORT.
OPERATORS ANYBODY ELSE ON THE
QUEUE IN TEST FIND SUPPORT TIME
NOW. WITH THAT SAID I WILL GO
TO THOSE ON THE PHONE
OPPOSITION. OPERATORS WORK IN
THE QUEUE FOR THOSE IN
OPPOSITION THIS BILL AGAIN
WE'RE HEARING FROM THE OFFICE
OF THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
ELEVEN FORTY. OPERATORS ANYBODY
IN THE QUEUE. PLEASE ONE NINE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. WITH THAT
SAID OUR NEXT WILL GO ON TO THE
REMOTE VIDEO STATION DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES THAT WOULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY OF SO
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION IF
ANY POSITION ON THE BILL NUMBER
OF COMMENTS. NONE OF SEEN NONE
NOW LET'S GO WITNESSES HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. DO WE HAVE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IF SO PLEASE COME
FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE. AND
PLEASE REFRAIN FROM TOUCHING
THE MICROPHONE STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY POSITION ON
THE BILL AND ANY BRIEF COMMENTS
SEE NONE OF THE ROOMS BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS- ANY
COMMON. A MEMBER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS. SINAN A SECOND WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER COOLEY
SECOND BY THE COOPER OF LIKE
JULY TO GO AHEAD AND CLOSE YES
I MUST ADMIT THE NORMALLY WE
WOULD HAVE ONE OF OUR LOCAL
FIREFIGHTERS TESTIFYING BUT
RIGHT NOW IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
THEY'RE A LITTLE BIT BUSY SO
PLEASE INDULGE- THEY'RE BOTH
THE EMPLOYEES AND BOTH
ORGANIZATIONS ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS LET'S GIVE THEM THE
BENEFIT THEIR BARGAIN I ASK FOR
YOUR- VOTE. THANK YOU WITH THAT
SAID THIS BILL MAKES SENSE TO
ME BECAUSE IT MAKES THINGS MORE
EFFICIENT REGARDING FIRE.
PROTECTION SERVICES FOR THE
DISTRICT WILL ALSO PRESENT
PRESERVING THE EXISTING
RETIREMENT BENEFIT FROM THE
BOYS. OF SUCCESSOR AGENCY I'M
ALSO RECOMMENDING I WROTE SO
THAT MR SECRETARY CALDERON. THE
MOTION IS WITH RECOMMENDATION
IT'S AN AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRED. RODRIGUEZ HI
RODRIGUEZ HI VOEPEL. CERVANTES
COOLEY FACT COOLEY AYE COOPER
COOPER I FONG. O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL ON A MEASURE HAS FOUR
VOTES. IT MEASURES OUT WILL
KEEP THE WRONG OPEN FOR A
MISSING MEMBERS THANK YOU EVER.
TWENTY FOUR A MONTH. WHAT A
WHICH ONE COULD DO WORSE YEAH.
WE CAN TELL ABOUT THE MOVIE.
FOR THAT WE HAVE OF FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY NINE
SIXTY SEVEN GIORDANO WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- SENATE
AMENDMENTS CLARIFY. A TO THIS
BILL- CLARIFY THAT A PUBLIC
AGENCY MAY NOT AMEND ITS
CONTRACT WITH CALPERS TO
EXCLUDE GROUPS OF EMPLOYEES
THAT ERE PREVIOUSLY INCLUDED.
SEVERAL SERVICES SERVING
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
CONTRIBUTE A PORTION OF THEIR
EARNINGS TO THEIR CALPERS
PENSIONS. TRUSTING THEIR
INVESTMENT WILL PROVIDE A
SECURE RETIREMENT. MANY OF
THOSE EMPLOYEES INCLUDING
FIREFIGHTERS PERFORM CHANGERS
AND DEMANDING JOBS CONFIDENT
THAT THEIR PENSION BENEFITS
WILL ENSURE A SECOND A SECURE
FUTURE FOR THEIR FAMILIES. SOME
LOCAL AGENCIES HAVE DECIDED TO
GAMBLE ON A RISKY MODEL THAT
THE PRICE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES OF A
SECURE RETIREMENT. BY AMENDING
THEIR CONTRACTS TO EXCLUDE
CERTAIN GROUPS OF EMPLOYEES
FROM CALPERS BENEFITS. LIMITING
ACCESS TO CALPERS ROB CRITICAL
PUBLIC SAFETY WORKERS OF THE
PENSION BENEFITS AND FINANCIAL
SECURITY THEY DESERVE.
ADDITIONALLY HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF AGENCIES ADOPT THIS
MODEL THE LOSS OF CONTRIBUTIONS
TO CALPERS COULD DESTABILIZE
THE FUN AND ENDANGER THE
RETIREMENT BENEFITS OF ALL
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES. AB TWENTY
NINE SIXTY SEVEN. TO ENSURE
PUBLIC AGENCIES USE THE CALPERS
AMENDMENT PROCESS AS INTENDED
NOT TO CUT OUT SELECT GROUPS OF
EMPLOYEES FROM A SECURE
RETIREMENT. DOT TESTIFYING
MAYBE ON THE BILL IS CHRISTY
BOWMAN REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS I DON'T KNOW IF
SHE'S AVAILABLE ON THE PHONE
MISTER CHAIR. IF NOT I DO HAVE
JUST A COUPLE MORE COMMENTS.
ONE MOMENT I CAN OPEN CREEK
DECLINE ONE MOMENT. CURTIR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CHRISTY VALVE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
BEEN THE PRIMARY WITNESS QUEUE
BUT NOBODY NOBODY CAME TO GET
ME SO- IF I COULD JUST STAY ON
AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY SEVEN WE
ARE CO SPONSORS OF THE MEASURE
AND THEN VERY STRONG SUPPORT
HAVE YOU HAVE TO KEEP IT BRIEF
SO I'LL BE AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS. WE URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE OF
SUPPORT. OPERATORS ARE ANYONE
ELSE ON SUPPORT. IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE WALK
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO AT THE
TIME THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
OKAY CEMEX WILL GO TO THE LAW
THAT'S WHAT ALL THAT THERE'S
ONE OKAY NOW. PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE EIGHTEEN. THIS IS A AND
HER WHITE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT
SYSTEM IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
OPERATOR ANYBODY ELSE IN THE
QUEUE. NO I DON'T THINK HE'LL.
GOVERNOR TO GO THROUGH THOSE ON
THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION
OPERATORS WORK THROUGH THE
QUEUE FOR THOSE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL AGAIN WE'RE
HEARING FROM THE OPPOSITION ON
AB. TWENTY NINE SIXTY SEVEN.
ONE MOMENT WHILE WE COLLECT
ONLINE NUMBER.
AT NINE TWENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I TWENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MEMBERS
THIS IS DYLAN GIVENS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION CALLING OPPOSITION
AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY SEVEN I
WILL TRY TO KEEP THIS BRIEF
FAMILIAR IMAGES TRYING TO WRAP
UP EXTRA QUICKLY. I WOULD LIKE
TO START BY SAYING THAT THAT
CITIES ALONG RECORD OF TO FIND.
CONTRIBUTIONS AS A WAY TO
ATTRACT AND RETAIN EMPLOYEES
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO-
ARE OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
NINE FIFTY SEVEN BASED ON THE
UNDERSTANDING PUBLIC AGENCIES
HAVE A DUTY TO RESPONSIBLY
MANAGE PUBLIC FINANCES. IN A
PUBLIC AGENCY DETERMINES THAT
DEFINED. BENEFIT PENSIONS BUT
SOMETHING THEY CANNOT OF. TO
RETAIN THE OF WITH CAL. AND
THERE AND TO MANAGE THOSE COSTS
ON A CASE BY BASIS. CURRENTLY
THE PUBLICLY IT IS DETERMINES
THAT CA NO LONGER AFFORD BY
BENEFIT CONTRIBUTIONS. I WOULD
LIKE TO SET UP FOR A POOR ONE
CUT STYLE PLAN. THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO EITHER LEAVE THE
SYSTEM ENTIRELY OR AMENDED
CONTRACT WITH CALPERS WHICH
CALPERS HAS TO APPROVE IF THEY
BELIEVE IN IT WOULD DESTABILIZE
THE FUND THEY WANT TO PROVE IT.
THEN THEY CAN REMOVE CERTAIN
CLASSIFICATIONS OF EMPLOYEES
FROM THE PENSION CONTRACT WITH
CALPERS OR IN THE CASE OF
PLACENTIA- REMOVE THE
CLASSIFICATION PLEASE WITH NO
ACTIVE EMPLOYEES UNDER CONTRACT
AND THEN HIRE EMPLOYEES AND THE
CLASSIFICATION UNDER DIFFERENT
PLANTS- WHAT THEY'RE ASKING FOR
ADDITIONAL TO ADDRESS OUR
PENSION COSTS. THE BILL TAKES A
TOOL AWAY BY STATING THAT BY
SAYING IT'S ALL OR NOTHING.
WHETHER PROVIDED DEFINED
BENEFIT PENSION TO ALL
EMPLOYEES OR NOT. UNFORTUNATELY
BUT THE DRAMATIC INCREASE IN
PENSION COSTS THAT WE'VE BEEN
EXPERIENCING THAT MAY RESULT AT
THAT MAY RESULT IN MORE
EMPLOYEES WITHOUT DEFINED
BENEFIT PENSION. RATHER THAN
LET IT THIS BILL SEEKS. NO TO
THAT PUBLIC AGENCIES EXACT SAME
GET THIS BILL TO TAKE THE ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH BY
LIMITING REALLY USED TO. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
OUR POSITION. AND I ASK FOR YOU
KNOW ABOUT. THANK YOU OP CENTER
ELSE IN THE- WE HAVE BLIND SIX
BUT NOT THAT ONE NO THEY'RE
GONNA KILL AT THE TIME. OKAY
SEEN THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE WE'LL GO TO THE VIDEO
REMOTE STATIONS DO WE HAVE. ANY
WITNESSES THAT WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY. IF SO PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION OF ANY
POSITION ON THE BILL ENDING
BRIEF COMMENTS. SEE NON NOW
LET'S GO TO WITNESSES HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. TO HAVE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IF SO PLEASE COME
FOR TO THE MICROPHONE AND
WITHOUT. TOUCHING PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION OF ANY
POSITION ON THE BILL ON A BRIEF
COMMENTS. SAY NONE. A BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY
TWENTY QUESTIONS COME OUT OF.
WE HAVE A MOTION MISTER COOPER
AND SECONDED BY SUMMER COOLEY.
A SOME REFLECT CLOSE- YES THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND I
THINK THE GENTLEMAN FROM THE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
MADE MY POINT- WHAT HE REALLY
ARTICULATED WAS THAT THEY DON'T
DESIRE TO OFFER A PENSION PLAN.
AND WHAT WE'RE SEEKING HERE TO
DO IS TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
PROMISED A PENSION OR- HAVE A
JOB THAT MISSISSIPPI TO PENSION
BECAUSE THE DAY THAT THE
DANGEROUS NATURE OF THE JOB I
GET THAT PENSION WHAT WE DON'T
WANT TO SEE IN CALIFORNIA IS
THAT SUB GOVERNMENT START
POPPING UP. AND UNDER THAT WERE
MAYBE FORMALLY SPECIAL
DISTRICTS CENTER AND OFFERING
AND NOT OFFERING PENSION PLANS
IT'S ACTUALLY TRYING TO DITCH
THAT PENSION PLAN AND GET
AROUND- THE LEGAL OBLIGATION
ARGUABLY SO WITH THAT I JUST
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FUTURE. THANK
WITHOUT. AWESOME REMOTE
HONORABLY THIS BILL CLOSES THE
LOOPHOLE THAT PREVENTS THE
INAPPROPRIATE USE OF THE
CALPERS AGENCY. CONTRACTING
PROCESS IN THE FUTURE TO
EXCLUDE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES FROM A
DEFINED BENEFIT RETIREMENT. AT
THE END OF THE DAY I BELIEVE
THAT ALL PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
SHOULD HAVE A DEFINED BENEFIT
RETIREMENT PLANS. I'M ALSO
RECOMMENDING THEM IPHONES WITH
THE SECRETARY CALDERON. THE
MOTION AS WITH RECOMMENDATION
IT'S AN AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRED. RODRIGUEZ HI
RODRIGUEZ HI VOEPEL. CERVANTES
COOLEY COOLEY AYE COOPER COOPER
HI FONG. O'DONNELL FIVE
O'DONNELL I MISTER CHAIR THAT
HAS FOUR VOTES FOR THAT MOTION
IS OCT WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
FOR MISSION MEMBERS. HAVE A
LOOK AT THE- ONE HUNDRED OF ONE
OF RISK WHAT A DIFFERENCE A-
YEAH I'M DOING LOOKS LIKE THIS
WILL. THE KIDS ARE GOING TO DO
IT. I PEOPLE WHO DON'T KNOW WHO
MISTER. I DON'T DO IT. OKAY WE
ARE HERE TAKE A UP BABY TWENTY
A ONE EIGHT COMMITTEE OF
PROBLEM RETIREMENT SO AB TWENTY
ONE A ONE PRINCIPAL AUTHOR IS-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ. I
MISS RODRIGUEZ ASHLEY TO BEGIN
THAT PRESENTATION WHEN YOU ARE
READY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN WAS IMPRISONING AB
TWENTY ONE OH ONE WHICH IS BACK
IN THE SENATE CONCURRENCE.
SENATE MEMBERS COMBINE THREE
SEPARATE- TECHNICAL CLEANUP
DATA THAT WERE INTRODUCED FOR
CALPERS AND CAL STIRS THE
NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN ACT
COUNTY RETIREMENT SYSTEMS
SINGLE BILL. PERSPECTIVES FROM
A VOTE. OKAY BUT MOVED TO
SECOND IN OUR WE WANT TO GO TO
THE OPERATOR NOW AND OPEN THE
LINES FOR WITNESSES TO SUPPORT.
ADAM OPERATOR. OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINES.
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. I
AM EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU THIS IS ANDREW WHITE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT SYSTEM AND
SPOKE IN SUPPORT OF THE SPONSOR.
THANK YOU MISTER WHITE. OTHER
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES. ON THE
PHONE LINE BLIND TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BRYMBO CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MR BRAMBLE.
OTHER ADDITIONAL WITNESSES SITE
NINETEEN. MY NINETEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GEORGE ALLEN MARTINEZ
WAY WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE THERE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT. THAT'S
LINE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS DEREK
LINKED WITH THE OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE OH
ONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ARE
THERE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WE
HAVE NINE OR FOURTEEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON JENNIFER BAKER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RETIRED TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS BAKER ADDITIONAL.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE LINES. AT THIS TIME THERE
IS NOT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
WILL YOU OPEN THE PHONE LINES
FOR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
IT'S PAST ONE THAT THEIR IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION. THIS TIME
THERE IS NO ONE IN Q. VERY GOOD
ARE THERE ANY OTHERS ON THE
PHONE FOR A BI. TWENTY OH ONE.
AND AGAIN AT THIS TIME THERE'S
NO ONE IN Q. VERY GOOD THANK
YOU FOR THAT ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES JOIN US VIA VIDEO IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AND I
INFORMED THERE ARE NO WITNESSES
IN THE VIDEO STATION. SUPPORT
OFFERS SESSION ARM. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN THE ROOM WITH
US IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IF
SO PLEASE COME FORWARD RIGHT BE
FROM MARKS AND DO NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. AND NO WITNESSES
APPEARING AND PRESENT IN A
CERTAIN ROOM. I BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. ALL
RIGHT OF HEARING NONE WE THANK
YOU AUTHOR- DO YOU HAVE A- TO
HAVE A MOTION OR SECOND.
MOVEMENT-O'DONNELL SECONDED BY
MR FONG THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE FOR
STRUCTURE PROGRESS PRIVATE.
OKAY RESEARCH PLEASE THE ROLL
ON AB TWENTY ONE OH ONE IT IS-
MOVED TO SECONDED THAT IT BE
APPROVED. WITH THERE WERE TAKEN
UP FOR SENATE AMENDMENTS THAT'S
CORRECT. CORRECT THE MOTION IS
WITH RECOMMENDATION IT'S
SYNONYMOUS BE CONCURRED ADDING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RODRIGUEZ
HI RODRIGUEZ HI VOEPEL.
CERVANTES COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE
COOPER- COOPER HI FONG. FONG I
O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL HI MISTER
CHAIR THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTES
OKAY THAT MEASURE IS PASSED.
FROM AT THIS TIME CAN WE GO
THROUGH THE ROLE AGAIN BILLS
PEOPLE ADDED ON TO CONSENT. ALL
OF THE CONTENT. ON ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN FORTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE FONG. FONG
HI MR THE HAS FIVE VOTES OKAY-
AB ELEVEN FORTY IS OUT. FIVE
ZERO. ON ASSEMBLY BILL TWO NINE
SIX SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
O'DONNELL FONG. FONG NOVEL
RESEARCHER THE BILL'S FOUR TO
ONE. THAT MEASURE IS PASSED ON
A FOUR ONE VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND THAT IS IT MOST WE
HAVE MEMBERS WHO STILL WANT TO
SHOW UP TO VOTE MISTER CHAIR.
THE LEGAL OPEN. IT WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR A FEW MOMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SOME OF.
REPUBLICAN LIFE WHICH SEVEN
PAPA WITH. YEAH CHAIR. YEAH. ON
WHICH AND CALL THE OFFICE.
PUBLIC. AND I KNOW. IN THIS
ORDER. WHAT.
YEAH.
YEAH SORRY
THE- HI. OKAY YEAH.
YEAH. RIGHT.
OKAY OKAY.
SECRETARY COULD YOU
OPEN THE ROLE ON OUR BILLS WE
HAVE TODAY OUR FIRST ONE WE HAD
OF A. B. E. ELEVEN FORTY
SECRETARY CAN CALL THE MISSING
MEMBERS ON. THE FIRST ONE AB
ELEVEN FORTY CERVANTES
CERVANTES HI DIVESTITURE THAT
SIX TO ZERO THE MOTION IS OUT
SIX ZERO OUR NEXT ONE IS AB
TWENTY ONE OH ONE SECRETARY
CALLED THE MISSING MEMBERS
CERVANTES CERVANTES HI MISTER
KERR SIX TO ZERO THE MOTION
WITHOUT SIX ZERO- NEXT ONE THE
FOLLOWING NUMBER THREE A. B.
TWENTY NINE SIXTY SEVEN
SECRETARY CALLED THE MISSING
NUMBER. CERVANTES CERVANTES HI
MISTER CHAIR FIVE TO ONE. THE
MOTION IS OUT FIVE TWO ONE AND
WITH THAT SAID THIS CONCLUDES
OUR- FIRST OF MEETING COMMITTEE
REFERRING THANK ALL BY.